le père ferdinand de severina plus de
paroissiens ils sont tous morts ou
disparus
alors comme chaque matin depuis que la
mer s'est retirée à banda aceh le padre
fait le tour des mosquées en espérant de
nouvelles
excusez moi je cherche des corps de
chrétiens
quelqu'un m'a dit qu'il y en avait deux
derrière la mosquée
vous savez les corps sont tellement
gonflée qu'on ne sait plus qui est
catholique et qui est musulman mais il
ya bien des corps là bas derrière
y'a pas de soucis y en a plein les
soldats m'explique qu'il y a des corps
un peu plus loin je vais peut-être
pouvoir les bénir
c'est difficile de voir toutes ces
destructions
c'est plus douloureux que je ne pensais
j'aimerais tant trouvé les corps de mes
chers paroissiens
c'est probable qu'ils aient été
regroupées ici avec d'autres
alors je vais tous les bénir car en fait
il n'ya qu'un paradis pour les croyants
qu'ils soient chrétiens ou pas
cela faisait trente ans que le padre
severi veiller sur les 500 m de sa
paroisse une mission divine en terre
d'islam à laquelle il ne renoncera pour
renault
ma taille sur les hauteurs de banda aceh
un camp parmi les dizaines mise en place
après le tsunami pour accueillir les
réfugiés celui ci est géré par la croix
rouge il regroupe 300 familles
le padre saberi a décidé de passer la
journée ici il n'a que quelques bonbons
à offrir aux réfugiés
quelques bonbons et aussi quelques
conseils
vous êtes passé prendre des médicaments
au centre
et le petit il va bien
moi je vais vous dire
je sais pourquoi ce drame est arrivé
c'est à cause de la grande fête qu'il y
a eu la veille qu'elle m'explique c'est
que d'après leurs croyances le
tremblement de terre est arrivé parce
que ils faisaient une fête sans retenue
il ne faut pas croire des choses
pareilles
moi
j'essaye de leur expliquer que ce n'est
pas une punition de dieu
et qu'il n'y a aucune raison que la
province la tchéquie a déjà tellement
souffert soient punis par un tel
cataclysme
à quelques mètres de là un prêche
improvisé sur le bord de la route autre
ton autre registre
à la ne punit pas sans raison à la 92e
test pas allah ne vous a pas oubliés
même si parfois ses gestes nous semble
incompréhensible
mais maintenant il faut oublier le passé
il faut se tourner vers l'avenir se
remettre au travail hier à che pleurait
mais aujourd'hui il faut que les gens
date chez se remettent au travail
ceux qui veulent travailler avec moi
lever la main
grâce à son discours je me sens enfin
très heureuse
j'espère que tous les jeunes qui sont
ici bon bien écouter et suivre son
exemple
ce qui nous est arrivé est une punition
de dieu il nous a punis pour nos péchés
après seulement 15 minutes de sermons
près de 50 jeunes réfugiés vont se
porter volontaires
le padre severi lui a passé la journée à
chercher des chrétiens à l'intérieur du
camp il n'en a pas trouvé un seul
sambo le prédicateur est arrivé de
jakarta la capitale indonésienne il y a
quelques jours il fait partie d'une des
milices islamistes les plus radicales et
les plus redoutés d'indonésie le front
de défense de l'islam
sa mission ramener les musulmans de
cette région dans le droit chemin vers
l'avant
le camp compte déjà 150 jeunes soldats
eux aussi tout juste arrivé de jakarta
en place allez allez bouger vous comptez
vous maintenant
dans un autre archipel du pays les
moluques des miliciens de cette
organisation sont accusés d'avoir
massacré des centaines de chrétiens au
nom de la guerre sainte
aujourd'hui nous allons récupérer les
corps des victimes
nous sommes tous musulmans nous sommes
tous des frères
l'union fait la force c'est bien compris
c'est bien compris
aux côtés de sambo le prédicateur les
cadres de la milice supervise le bon
déroulement des opérations
lui a fait ses études de théologie au
yémen
lui c'était en egypte
je pense qu'il va falloir faire venir
d'autres volontaires de jakarta on va
avoir besoin de renforts
dans une semaine 800 musiciens
supplémentaires doivent arriver à banda
aceh et cela en toute légalité
notre organisation est inscrite
officiellement au bureau gouvernemental
date chez ce sont les autorités qui ont
fait appel à nous nous n'avons pas
d'autre but ici que d'aider les
habitants nous n'avons pas l'intention
de prendre le pouvoir ici une fois que
le travail est terminé nous leur
laisserons les commandes
peut-être mais d'ici la fin du mois la
milice espère pouvoir compter sur 5000
volontaires
j'espère que tout le monde a bien
conscience du travail qui nous attend je
veux que vous neil exemple
lorsque vous ramasserez les cadavres il
est strictement interdit de voler les
objets de valeur
si jamais vous en trouvez sur les corps
que ce soit des bijoux de l'or ou de
l'argent
il faut tout de suite mettre ces objets
dans un sac et nous les apporter le plus
rapidement possible il ne faut surtout
pas que l'on nous considère comme des
voleurs c'est bien compris pour tout le
monde
quelques versets du coran il parle de
martyrs et de djihad et ils sont chantés
sur un air propre milice
le bataillon des 50 nouvelles recrues ne
connaît pas encore toutes les paroles
mais se souvient déjà de l'air les
autres soldats ont intégré la milice il
ya déjà plusieurs mois à jakarta il
était chargé de mettre le feu aux
magasins et aux restaurants qui servent
de l'alcool
le palais du gouverneur de banda aceh a
été transformée en centre de
commandement des opérations humanitaires
c'est ici que le gouvernement indonésien
oriente accrédités définit les missions
de chaque nouvel arrivant sur l'île de
sumatra au milieu des habitués de
l'urgence humanitaire à nouveau logo et
une nouvelle couleur
l'église de scientologie à hollywood tom
cruise et john travolta sont les
défenseurs les plus ardents de la secte
mais sur le terrain ce sont des hommes
comme le révérend nick broadhurst qui
sont aux commandes
c'est cet homme qui est chargé des
accréditations
il n'a jamais entendu parler de l'église
de scientologie
est notre spécialité c'est le traitement
mentale des victimes traumatisées
lorsque les gens survivent à une telle
tragédie ils en gardent des séquelles
et vous devez savoir aussi que les
volontaires qui viennent ici pour aider
eux aussi ont des séquelles notre
méthode permet à tout le monde de guérir
plus rapidement
pour obtenir son accréditation
nick insiste pour faire une
démonstration
tenez venez vous asseoir ici
non en fait on va ce soir là bas
bon alors ce que je vais vous demander
de faire c'est de fermer les yeux et
lorsque la séance se terminera vous
sentir la différence j'en suis sûr ce
que je veux faire c'est que je vais vous
demander de bien sentir mon blog je vous
demande pardon je vais vous demander de
se sentir mon doigt par exemple je vais
vous demander santé mon doigt ouais et
vous me répondez oui en anglais ou
autres langues ce que je suis en train
de faire c'est simplement de suivre les
terminaisons nerveuses de votre corps
oui
santé mon doigt
bien santé mon doigt oui fabien
que
pendant la séance même les appels
d'urgence sont interdits
vingt minutes plus tard alors comment
vous sentez vous
oui je me sens plus détendu c'est sûr
en tout cas
j'apprécie vraiment votre démonstration
bon peut-être qu'on en fait un peu plus
à aller on en fait un peu plus mais qu
est-ce qu tenir un cahier ces attaques
l'église du padre severi est la seule de
la ville
elle a été construite par des hollandais
au début du siècle dernier
ici il n'y a pas d'urgence à nettoyer
plus personne ne vient
l'édifice est fissurée de partout mais
la structure a tenu bon le padre crois
aux miracles
de pic adam et eve ont été chassés du
paradis terrestre l'histoire de l'homme
n'a été qu'une suite de guerre de
catastrophe d'innovation de tremblement
de terre et de souffrance
il surfe rsm à la fille il bambino mais
regardez ici c'est l'enfant jésus il est
resté intact dans son
comment dit-on en italien dans son
berceau devant d'auteur
donc l'eau s'est arrêtée juste en
dessous de lui
l'eau n'a pas dépassé la troisième
marche
vous voyez je les laissais ici
volontairement depuis mon retour
pour montrer qu'au milieu de ce désordre
et que dans ce désespoir jésus reste
imperturbable
et qu'il continue à porter la bonne
parole une parole de consolation et
d'espoir
des paroles pour tenter de rassurer la
poignée de fidèles qui l'entourent ici
tout le monde sent bien qu'après le
tsunami un autre danger guette la
communauté chrétienne
nous attendons un miracle de dieu
pour nous donner la force de traverser
cette épreuve
et nous espérons surtout qu'il reste
encore une place dans cette ville
pour nous les chrétiens
dans le camion des nouvelles recrues le
sentiment d'excitation est palpable
c'est celui de ceux qui vont enfin faire
quelque chose pour conjurer le sort
tous ces jeunes ont perdu des proches
mais après seulement 24 heures passées
au sein du front de défense de l'islam
leur discours est déjà bien rodé
[Musique]
l'explication que nous donne l'islam
c'est que le tremblement de terre est
une punition divine qui frappe ceux qui
ne vivent pas comme de bons musulmans
vous savez à aceh beaucoup de croyants
faisait la fête il y en avait même
qu'ils buvaient de l'alcool et j'ai
entendu dire que des femmes voilées
entrer dans des églises chrétiennes
depuis le tsunami moi j'ai décidé d'être
au service de dieu des phrases apprise
par coeur pour donner un sens à
l'inexplicable
un discours qui ne va pas résister
longtemps à la violence de la réalité
tous reviennent pour la première fois
sur le site du désastre
[Musique]
douze jours après le tsunami c'est
encore plus de mille corps qui sont
retrouvés chaque jour dans les décombres
chargé le doucement
vers le sac là il y à son ventre qui
dépasse
il ya
maintenant je veux qu'on remplisse tout
le camion de cole compris
aller dépêchez-vous observations
également
ce qui est arrivé n'est pas une punition
de dieu car allah est bon
c'est simplement un avertissement pour
que tous les musulmans se remettent en
question et qu'il commence à suivre la
loi islamique ils obéissent au principe
du coran et à la parole divine et aux
recommandations du prophète
toute la journée les hélicoptères black
hawk de la marine américaine sont des
allers-retours pour acheminer l'aide
ça ne vous dérange pas la présence
d'américains
[Musique]
s'ils ne font qu'apporter de legs de la
nourriture des médicaments pas de
problème mais s'ils ont un autre but
alors nous les combattrons
ce sera la guerre
moi je leur dis regardez autour de vous
regardez tous ces musulmans qui sont
morts ici alors arrêtez le massacre en
irak d'autres musulmans arrêtez de tuer
c'est peut-être ça l'autre message que
dieu avant de faire passer avec ce
désastre
moi
oh mon dieu
pour les scientologues aussi l'heure est
venue de se confronter à la réalité
vous avez déjà vu quelque chose de
semblable non c'est bien pire que ce que
j'imaginais
vous savez à quoi ça me fait penser moi
la seule chose qui ressemble ce sont les
photos faites à hiroshima
et ça c'était en 1945 pas question pour
eux de toucher aux cadavres
officiellement s'ils sont là c'est pour
absorber les ondes négatives de ces
destructions pour aider au mieux les
survivants une méthode bien rodée qui
aurait selon eux fait ses preuves
pendant le tremblement de terre de kobé
au japon ou encore à new york après le
11 septembre
vous pensez que c'est important de venir
ici ça va vous aider à comprendre les
victimes bien sûr que ça va nous aider
c'est vraiment une bonne chose d'être
venu car on se rend compte de l'ampleur
de dégâts mais je vais vous dire si on
peut former deux à trois cents personnes
en plus de la quarantaine de
scientologues sur le terrain nous
pourrons alors aidé psychologiquement
les survivants de cette ville mais aussi
de toutes les autres villes touchées
c'est incroyable ce que vous dites les
psychologues ont besoin de faire des
années d'études recevoir leur diplôme
[Musique]
et au bout du compte ça peut aboutir à
du n'importe quoi non je vais vous dire
nous avons une technique infaillible
c'est ça notre force ça marche à chaque
fois quelle que soit la situation
c'est une technique simple ça n'a rien
de mystérieux ça c'est ce que les
psychologues veulent vous faire croire
et puis vous savez ils font beaucoup
d'argent en vendant des médicaments
en vous faisant croire qu'il n'ya qu'eux
qui peuvent aider la vérité c'est que la
scientologie va droit au but car nos
principes sont simples et donc commun à
tous les êtres humains
l'accusation portée contre les
psychologues frôle l'hypocrisie la secte
est réputé pour sa formidable capacité à
soutirer de l'argent à ses adeptes
soudain des soldats indonésiens
interpelle les scientologues ils
viennent de retrouver un survivant c'est
une tortue géante retrouvé sous un amas
de pierres c'est la vague qui l'a amenée
jusqu'ici elle est vivante mais sans
aucun doute traumatisé pour les
scientologues l'occasion rêvée de mettre
en pratique leurs théories
apparemment vous ne faites pas qu'aider
les humains une vie c'est une vie c'est
une loi universelle
c'est la première fois que je fais ça
une tortue principe reste le même
j'avais fait que suivre le système
nerveux oui mais le système nerveux du
quartier quand même différent oui mais
ça reste un être vivant
au sein du groupe un homme est chargé de
tout filmer
cet incroyable il s'agit de montrer aux
généreux donateurs de la secte comment
leur argent est utilisé sur le terrain
moi j'ai déjà soigné des chiens et des
chats mais j'avais une tortue
[Musique]
dix membres de l'église de scientologie
au chevet d'une tortue
la mer est à 5 km un voyage retour en
première classe pour la nouvelle
protégée des scientologues
t'inquiète pas ma grande on te ramène à
la mer
je crois que la marée monte
de rigueur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis pas de clarinette mais je pense
que nous allons bien soigner ses
patients
le soir même l'article et les photos de
l'événement sont en première page du
site de l'église de scientologie
juste à côté de la promotion du livre du
gourou de la secte
le texte est accompagnée d'un appel à
faire des dons pour l'église même ma
présence est exploité j'aurais paraît-il
qualifié le sauvetage de miracle faut
bien sûr
pas de miracle en vue du côté des
milices du front de défense de l'islam
c'est lors de l'enterrement pour les
cadavres ramassés dans la matinée c'est
toujours sambo le prédicateur qui
supervise les opérations
allaient pour remplir la fosse
doucement doucement faites le glisser
allez
un parent et bien
son beau vous les enterrer pour qu'il
soit face à la mecque
leur tête en direction d'un mac
enfin normalement selon le prophète
mohammed et la loi de dieu n'est mort
doivent être enterrés en direction de la
mecque
mais lorsque c'est une situation
d'urgence on est pauvre
il y encore deux jours cette mosquée
servait de morgue grâce au travail de
sambo et de ces volontaires le lieu de
culte va enfin pouvoir rouvrir ses
portes
c'est important de nettoyer cette
mosquée car il faut que les survivants
puissent revenir pour prier
pour donner aux gens une force
spirituelle et morale
hôpital public dahra panne depuis deux
jours c'est là que le révérend nique et
son équipe ont trouvé refuge pour
pratiquer leur séance d' assistance
spirituelle
ferme les yeux et on fait la même chose
qui hier au quai 50 patients traités
chaque jour le groupe a atteint sa
vitesse de croisière
qu'est ce qu'ils font là mais ce matin
un grain de sable va enrayer leur belle
opération de communication
ça n'a rien à voir avec la médecine ce
qu'ils font
moi je suis docteur je peux vous dire
que ce n'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
faire
demandez lui s'il se sent mieux demandez
lui
dis moi ce que tu sens une différence
il dit que en fait ça fait rien leur
truc
avec vos connaissances en traitement ça
change rien
et la séance d'hier
entre la séance d'hier et celle
d'aujourd'hui tu as senti quelque chose
pas de différence
mais notre scientologues n'en démord pas
il est convaincu de son pouvoir de
guérison
s'il vous plaît monsieur
vous arrêtiez
mon supérieur est là et tu voudrais vous
parler
dans la bon écoutez moi nous n'avons
plus besoin de votre aide pour l'instant
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît faites
les sorties allait dépêcher monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
embarrassé robe essaye de joindre son
supérieur le révérend nick n'a
je suis de la télévision française ne
filmaient pas désolé c'est quoi le
problème
nous n'avons pas besoin de ce genre
n'est pas pour l'instant
au clair ici monde
vous avez tout ce qu'il vous faut
nous n'avons pas besoin de votre aide
vous avez suffisamment docteur yes we
say compris
vous arriver à joindre me révélant nique
ça arrive souvent qu'on ne comprennent
pas ce que vous faites
oui enfin excusez moi mais je ne suis
pas habilité à parler aux médias on a
des gens pour ça
vous savez ici on est dans un pays
étranger il ya la barrière de la langue
l'église de scientologie nous apprend
qu'une bonne communication est
essentielle
je ne suis pas très inquiet
je suis désolé si nous avons offenser
qui que ce soit et je reviendrai avec
quelqu'un qui pourra vous expliquer ce
que nous faisons
vous savez si le docteur hendra et là
c'est lui qui nous a dit que l'on
pouvait venir
bon eh bien je reviendrai avec d'autres
membres pour mieux vous expliquer notre
démarche merci
depuis le tremblement de terre c'est la
première fois que les mosquées sont
ouvertes fidèles c'est le grand jour
pour sambo le prédicateur grâce à sa
tournée des camps de réfugiés il a déjà
recruté plus de 200 nouveaux membres
dans sa milice comme promis c'est
volontaire de choc ont réussi à tout
nettoyer pour la grande prière du
vendredi
regardez
regardez autour de vous
je ne pense pas qu avant ce drame les
mosquées étaient aussi remplissent
[Musique]
alors vous pensez que c'est une
renaissance de l'islam ici à aceh si
dieu le veut
j'espère que ce sera la première étape
de ce renouveau de l'islam h
[Musique]
l'opération de séduction des ultras
radicaux du front de défense de l'islam
est une réussite la preuve même dans
cette mosquée réputé pour sa modération
et sa tolérance les miliciens se mélange
avec les habitués les dignitaires
religieux du quartier ont même tenu à
honorer sambo pour l'efficacité de son
aide
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui ferai le
prêche pour fortifier les âmes des
fidèles
[Musique]
vous savez
c'est ma mission
à la craie le monde à la le pouvoir de
le détruire s'ils le veulent
allah est tout puissant
quinze jours après leur arrivée les
milices du front de défense de l'islam
sont une force avec laquelle il faudra
désormais compter à banda aceh
ça